تتقلص خيارات الناخب التركي ويحتدم السباق
في معركه انتخابيه ربما تكون هي الاصعب في
تاريخ الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
فهذا محرم انجيء زعيم حزب البلد يرفع
الرايه البيضاء
وينسحب من السباق الانتخابي قبيل ايام من
الاقتراع
اسحب اسمي من الترشح للرئاسه وانسحبه من
السباق انا افعل ذلك من اجل بلدي حاولت
توفير قناه جديده للناخبين لكنني فشلت
عندما تخسر المعارضه في الانتخابات
سيلوموننا فلن نعطيهم اي اعذار اريد
تصويتا من كل بيت لحزب الوطن ولكنني انسحب
من الترشح للرئاسه
[تصفيق]
اما المرشح عن تحالف الاجداد سنانوجان فما
زال يواصل نضاله حتى النهايه ونفى
الشائعات عن تمهيده للانسحاب
فيما يواصل زعيم حزب الشعب كمال كليتش دار
اوغلو المنافس الابرز لرجب طيب اردوغان
برنامجه الانتخابي الذي عرف ببساطته واتخذ
من تحسين الواقع المعيشي نقطه بدايه
وارتكاز لسياسته
اما اردوغان المحارب للفوز بعقد ثالث لحكم
البلاد فوعد بجمهوريه منفتحه على العالم
اجمع
وبين من يعد بجعل تركيا قويه منفتحه وبين
من يدعو لجعلها ديموقراطيه يبقى الفصل بيد
الناخبين الذين ستحدد اوراق اقتراعهم اسم
الرئيس المقبل لتركيا سلام المحاميد
العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات